geflüchtete zur Arbeit zwingen
populistischer Vorschlag oder Modell für
die Zukunft
Baden-Württembergs Landkreise fordern
eine Arbeitspflicht für Flüchtlinge ich
will wissen kann das funktionieren
in der Erstaufnahme für geflüchtete in
Ellwangen treffe ich Adel er kommt aus
Syrien ist erst seit zwei Wochen in
Deutschland
als ich angekommen bin habe ich sofort
gesagt ich will arbeiten
zwingen musste ihn niemand für 80 Cent
pro Stunde Teilen er und die anderen
hier Teller aus Arbeiten in der Küche
der Flüchtlingsunterkunft
[Musik]
nach der zermürbenden Flucht nicht
durchhängen das ist Adele wichtig
ja ja
geregelte Tagesstruktur zu haben du
brauchst feste Zeiten zum arbeiten
lernen und Sport machen hier habe ich
Kontakt zu vielen Menschen manche können
nur arabisch ich spreche Englisch und
kann helfen
man muss sich anstrengen um anzukommen
nur ein kleiner Teil der geflüchteten
spricht englisch oder gar Deutsch
deshalb arbeitet fahrdien ehrenamtlich
als Übersetzer auch in der nahegelegenen
Klinik
ich habe eine große Bitte an die
deutsche Regierung und ich spreche sie
im Namen aller Flüchtlinge heraus helft
uns unsere Zukunft zu gestalten so wie
ich wollen viele junge Menschen hier
studieren und dann auch Arbeiten in
Deutschland
in flüchtlingseinrichtungen ist es jetzt
schon möglich Menschen zur Arbeit zu
verpflichten erzählt mir Leiter Berthold
weiß aber das sei im Moment nicht nötig
70 % von unseren ca 600 geflüchteten die
hier sind sind alleinreisende Männer da
haben wir eine riesen Bereitschaft zu
arbeiten die machen alle alles was so
anbieten wir haben Dolmetscher Aufgaben
die Leute arbeiten hier in der Küche sie
helfen der Hausmeisterei 80 Cent pro
Stunde natürlich jetzt ist es wenig und
manchmal schämt man sich auch ein
bisschen 80 Cent in der Stunde heißt 5
Euro am Tag sind 20 in der Woche sind
knapp 100 im Monat
alle geflüchteten so oder so ähnlich zu
gemeinnütziger oder regulärer Arbeit
verpflichten dass es die Vision von
Baden-Württembergs Landkreisen in
Tübingen erklärt mir landradio Achim
Walter diese Idee Arbeit für alle so
schnelles geht das soll für mehr
Akzeptanz von geflüchteten sorgen im
Grunde genommen brauchen wir zwei Dinge
zum einen die Möglichkeit als untere
Ausländerbehörden auch Menschen zu
verpflichten zum einen und zum anderen
auch die Möglichkeit Leistungen zu
kürzen wenn dieser Verpflichtung nicht
nachgekommen wird
Asylbewerber in
Gemeinschaftsunterkünften bekommen 410
Euro monatlich bisher besteht für sie in
den ersten drei Monaten ein
Arbeitsverbot nur Ukrainer dürfen sofort
arbeiten und beziehen gleich Bürgergeld
in Höhe von 502 Euro plus Wohnkosten ich
glaube wir dürfen die Menschen nicht zu
fürsorgeempfängern degradieren die haben
sich durch verschiedene Länder
durchgeschlagen ich sage immer das sind
echte organisationstalente
auch drunter die Kräfte die müssen wir
im Grunde genommen auch abgreifen für
unseren Arbeitsmarkt
nur wer soll das organisieren wir fragen
einen der beide Seiten kennt rihan al
scheppel hat weltweit Schlagzeilen
gemacht weil er als syrischer
geflüchteter zum Bürgermeister gewählt
wurde im konservativen Ostelsheim eine
Arbeitspflicht für alle findet er
schwierig den Vorschlag halte ich für
wenig realistisch zumal wir genau wissen
dass dieser Pflicht nachher von den
Kommunen die ohnehin ausgelastet sind
umgesetzt werden muss
ich würde
eher mehr bei denjenigen Ansätzen die
bereits als anerkannte geflüchtete
gelten deutschland müsse mehr Druck auf
seine Einwanderer ausüben ich halte so
ein Druck für wichtig und
gesellschaftlich geboten denn es darf
aus meiner Sicht nicht der Eindruck
entstehen es leben hier Menschen die nur
von dem System leben dürfen ohne
Pflichten nachzugehen also Fördern und
Fordern statt Gemeinden Jobs verteilen
zu lassen fordert als Schädel ein
soziales Pflichtjahr für Einwanderer mit
Bleiberecht ich begleite ihn in eine
Flüchtlingsunterkunft dort weckt er die
Bewohner alle Bürgermeister
viele geflüchtete wie Ramsi rutschen in
die Depression weil sie sich zum
Nichtstun verdammt fühlen
ich würde der Gesellschaft so gerne was
zurückgeben dafür dass ich hier
aufgenommen wurde ich würde auch
ehrenamtlich arbeiten ohne Geld dafür zu
bekommen aber er scheitert an dem wie an
den bürokratischen Hürden das ist auch
die Erfahrung vieler Verbände gerade
hängt ein Metzger an der Strippe des
Flüchtlingsrats er möchte einen Mann aus
Gambia ausbilden aber die Behörden sagen
nein
die sagen ich würde gar nicht möchte ich
bin dabei und ist aber danach an der
Behörde schon das gibt's ja nicht
fassungslos gemacht also solche Fälle
erreichen uns eigentlich ständig die
bürokratischen Hürden sind schon extrem
hoch also sowohl erstmal herauszufinden
welche Möglichkeiten hat man in den
Erwerbstätigkeit aufzunehmen also die
rechtlichen Hürden auf der einen Seite
dann die Kommunikation mit den Behörden
tatsächlich da überhaupt erstmal einen
Termin zu bekommen eine Rückmeldung zu
bekommen
geflüchtete die Arbeit suchen
Arbeitgeber die Mitarbeiter brauchen
Behörden die sich quer stellen oder
nicht erreichbar sind das erlebt auch
der Leiter der Erstaufnahme in Ellwangen
Tag täglich wenn wir unsere öffentliche
Verwaltung nicht entsprechend ausstatten
dann können wir das Thema
Arbeitsverpflichtung was ja auch über
die über die Ausländerbehörden laufen
müsste das würde sich noch viel viel
schwieriger gestalten wie jetzt schon
er zeigt mir den Infopoint an dem viele
Flüchtlinge kurz nach ihrer Ankunft
schon nach Arbeit fragen
93 Familienangebote 94 aber nicht so
anschauen haben wir für Familien
eigentlich noch viel mehr Platz als für
Männer oder
im Moment kommen vor allem junge Männer
aus Syrien und der Türkei wenn sie
Arbeit gefunden haben geht der Kampf mit
den Behörden los
jedes Mal muss die zuständige
Ausländerbehörde bei der Agentur
verarbeiten Nachfragen
dreiseitiges Formular ausfüllen ob
dieser Mensch nicht im EU-Europäer den
Arbeitsplatz wegnimmt für mich
eigentlich in der aktuellen Situation wo
alle händeringend nach Arbeitskräften
suchen eine völlig absurde Geschichte
zurück zu Adel aus Syrien er ist
eigentlich Ingenieur würde gerne in
seinem Beruf arbeiten statt an der
Spülmaschine aber diese Hoffnung wurde
ihm schon genommen
das ist alles sehr kompliziert wird
mindestens ein Jahr dauern fünf sechs
Monate wären gut ein Jahr ist viel zu
lang
das muss schneller gehen unkomplizierter
sein fordert der Landrat als ich ihn mit
solchen Beispielen konfrontiere
ich bin durchaus dafür alle für alle
sofort die Möglichkeit zu schaffen zu
arbeiten kenne keinen Gastronomen der
nicht klagt dass er keine Menschen mehr
hat die beispielsweise in der Küche
helfen
das seine Partei die CDU diese Hürden
mit eingeführt hat um Zuwanderung zu
begrenzen ist ihm egal Deutschland muss
jetzt Umsteuern finden er und alle
anderen mit denen ich gesprochen habe
[Musik]